hello welcome back to trigonometry we're
gonna take a little break from my usual
serious interviews and just read out
some of the horrible hateful [ __ ] you've
been sending us absolutely I'm
particularly looking forward to it
because I don't get exposed to
anti-semitism enough so there we go
fantastic well let's get cracking
Francis so the first one is large
monster says one of the hosts looks like
Louis Carew crossed with the beaver he's
talking about me mate no no no no
Specter 969 says another thought that
proved before but Constantine does look
a little bit like a Russian Pakistani
Rick Grimes pleasing the next episode
can you shout Coral a few times see the
most offensive thing about that is I
don't know who Rick Grimes is because
I'm Russian so it's basically
anti-russian racism yeah and there's no
such thing as Russian Pakistani except
me
yeah exactly obviously me alright oh
yeah here we go the guy with the glasses
laughs like a flirty schoolgirl there's
not as [ __ ] oh yeah and let's be
honest the fact that you put the words
flirty in schoolgirl together means
you've just outed yourself as a Peter I
think I've added myself as a pedo by
saying yeah no it's [ __ ] yeah hey
you have as well anyway poopoo
said what is Constantine's race even he
looks like he's from everywhere that is
actually very true no mate because you
don't look like you're from here regal T
type in an effort to not appear
one-sided Beatles man goes maximum cut
yeah yeah that's probably true yeah you
do that
I do go maximum cut or as its otherwise
no displaying empathy okay so because
who could be oh this is what Al said
because who could be a better expert on
white identity then a mixed race
left-wing Jew give me a break I'm not
[ __ ] left-wing I'll take all the other
insults by the way where's it al should
not be out no it's a capital a space out
okay I like Constantine but it's so
obvious how these people operate
correct how do I operate well doing your
Jewish [ __ ] once they hear on these kind
of subjects he will invite a
chosen to spread anti-white prop again
Prince abrupted dy propaganda for me I
like that and subversion notjust
anti-white propaganda there's also going
to be some subversion but that's what
the Jews do man let's go back to you
looking ugly Francis I know our aces are
still around but let that haircut go
mate the 90s aren't coming back their
90s will always be alive in my heart
simple and it will never die and on your
head yeah ride it share gold he says you
guys look blazed with the count before
you recorded this Constantine looks high
as [ __ ] I wish that was true man yeah
it's mostly like I've sleep with me yeah
I wish we did we should start doing like
Joe Rogan just get stoned and then have
the conversation actually I think I
think if we invite thanking about we
could do our smoking episode we've
thanking it what we all do it Francis
you look like you have something to say
the whole time but didn't manage to get
it out that our constipation now
definitely grew with you in the
constipation yeah but he didn't look
like you had something to say he looked
like he had something to say and didn't
say it which is a boon and benefit to
all of us let's be honest I'll sure be
glad when that Ubisoft forgotten to
shave look is no longer fashionable on
men for heaven's sake either grow a real
beard Constantine or shave oh that's for
me is it yeah you're the one would like
three [ __ ] facial hairs no no am I
making fun of my facial yeah that's
James Simmons and he edited it James
you're a [ __ ] the guy in the red shirt
looks like a Poundland Brian Cox Brian
Cox is intelligent them ask you a
compliment it is quite a compliment even
if you were a Poundland Brian that would
still be an improvement of where you
actually what William said can someone
tell Constantine to stop slurping his
coffee throughout the interview you're
saying what we're all thinking
well done mark again this is this is so
unfair
you're the one that like there's a whole
meme of you trying to use a mug you and
what I'm into is where you take the mug
and you're like and it's me they make
fun of what is this [ __ ] yeah all right
so this is by mr. lovely this is gonna
be really nice yes
hey why interviewer did you know that
you have mild Treacher Collins syndrome
I don't know what they
it's where the bones on your face on the
developed well there's going to be a bit
of picture right here next to me how is
your hearing you have underdeveloped
bones in your face do you know I like
about that it's very very insulted and
salting yet at the same time weirdly
compassionate it is it's caring and
compassionate she's looking out for you
yeah well so at the same time destroying
my self-confidence yeah who knew my
mother was on YouTube okay right
Constantine looks like the Karate Kid if
he never met mr. Miyagi and that was
Stuart tanner wax on wax off
[ __ ] yep all right love
dougie I'm guessing this is about
Douglas when we get him on love dougie
great interview Frances get a haircut
you lay about and that's just me yeah
absolutely telling him but you won't
listen
yeah Jim fallow said trusted you to sell
a mug for 30 pounds by the way I should
take a moment and say that the point of
the reason the mugs are 30 pounds is not
because we think the mug is worth 30
pounds first of all we get very little
I'm doing the whole Jewish generation
we get like eight pounds per mug if it's
thirty pounds and also it's a way of you
supporting the show rather than just
buying a mug it's not like going into a
shop and buy them [ __ ] you guys can I
just say how lovely it is to have
members of the Labour Party watching the
show yep and this is by Beedrill am the
presenter on the right is a lizard just
saying does that mean yeah I'm on the
right yeah and then somebody else said
and I couldn't find the comment because
I think they deleted it but he said
Constantine looks like he blinks
sideways that's right I'm trying all
right well I still have a stack you've
run out has you get all the hateful yeah
I know
so come on it's correct alright let's
correct through it so Ricky Ravi all
says this is the first video I've seen
from this channel so excuse my ignorance
having said that does anyone else think
the guy in the red shirt looks like a
bargain Mike Myers
[Music]
why am I always bargain or Poundland
there's nothing wrong with these places
they provide a viable gonna make
alternative for poor people yeah yeah
that's what's wrong with it yeah polity
Francis's that bloke who spends all day
regarding himself middle-class until he
gets to the pub where you amps up his
cockney accent absolutely true I know so
many Francis types they mirror whoever
they're talking to but ask who they are
and turn into a gibbering mess it's a
very complicated and convoluted in size
it is it is and not particularly
accurate because it's actually the other
way round but you do amp up your whole
cockney thing
oh I'm not cockney yeah but you do amp
it up South London or whatever
same [ __ ] man zu B's physique says this
is about the interview with a rapper zou
Bisou Bisou physique highlighted the
complete lack of muscle and france's
arms excellent interview and interviewee
I love that that's what he thought was
excellent about it ya know like that it
pointed out how weak we are and it's
also you know I like about it as well as
incredibly homoerotic that comment
because what it really was is him
getting angry at the fact that he was
admiring Zubaz arms all the way through
the interview to be honest with the
managers if it was up for it I'd do it
okay that's good to know I'm sure I'm
sure he's hot man alright is it final
one is it me or does Francis look like
the guy with the head tattoo from the
hangover I don't know idea guys ah it's
it's a guy who's a dentist and he gets
beaten up and he gets just tooth tipped
and all the rest of it well I was pretty
accurate yeah dentist no no I didn't get
the grades but he knows also he's a [ __ ]
as well he reads the Guardian and takes
it literally oh yeah and also he gets
beat up by his wife and all the rest by
his wife yeah alright yeah he does have
actual proper [ __ ] oh yeah alright guys
well if you enjoyed that brutality keep
sending a smaller hair for comments will
make more fun of it and we will see you
very soon with another great episode
take care
see you later guys
[Music]